welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and captain america's mission is
not yet over in the mcu
with chris evans reported to be in talks
to return as steve rogers in an upcoming
marvel installment
now chris evans tweeted about this news
to me but yeah yeah
okay we have heard avengers actors
denied these casting reports before
that actually isn't a real thing several
months later
jennifer walters will be played by the
talented and emmy award-winning
tatiana maslany it's pretty clear these
actors are contractually obligated to
deny tonight deny until papa feige
throws on his announcement hat
not to overshadow wanna vision's
premiere weekend i'm still in the
process of exhaustively second guessing
everything agnes says for mephisto clues
but this is huge
news other than vision coming back from
the dead cap is the first supposedly
retired avenger to
return in marvel's future and based on
what we know we have a few pretty clear
options of what that story could be
i'm gonna break it down for you oh but
reminder that our merch partners at epic
hero shop are giving away 10 playstation
5's
you enter by following their new youtube
channel epic hero labs and filling out
the form at epic heroshop.com
giveaway they will announce a new winner
every 10 000 subscribers they get
and there's lots of ways to get new
entries to that giveaway at their
website epicgearshop.com
giveaway and speaking of merch of course
our new latest obsession shirt an
unusual couple vision themed is
amazing it's got secret augmented
reality easter eggs you can get that at
newrockstarsmerge.com
okay so this news is coming from
deadline reporting that though the deal
is not yet closed
chris evans is set to return as cap in
at least one marvel title with the door
open for a second film
after that they added that it's unlikely
to be another captain america
installment and more likely to be
similar to what robert downey jr did
showing up in civil war in spider-man
homecoming and chef which is mcu in my
head cannon
now again chris evans tweeted news to me
and then joked with knives out co-star
jamie lee curtis about her playing his
mom and praised all the gifts that he
got in response to this story back in
2019 scarlett johansson asked chris
evans about whether he would ever want
to come back to play cap and that's what
he said
it's not a hard no it's not a hard no
but it's not
a a an eager an either you know
i think cap had such a tricky arc to
to to stick the landing you know and i
think they did a really nice job
if you're gonna revisit it you know it
you can't be a cash grab
it can't be just because audiences would
be excited
there has to be what are we revealing
what are we adding to the story so
a lot of things would have to come
together i agree chris evans well it's
not like you need my consent but you got
it you got it for everything
this next cap film must expand cap's
story without undoing or overshadowing
his arc in the infinity saga which was i
would argue
of all the avengers the best character
journey across the films that's largely
thanks to the infinity war in-game
screenwriters marcus mcfeely being the
same dudes who wrote captain america
civil war and winter soldier in the
first cap film
across seven whole movies they did what
few franchises in cinema history have
done
they avoided completely screwed up by
character story across a franchise and
no one should ever screw with that
miracle
however these guys script for end game
especially the scene with old cap
definitely left us with questions like
where did old cap come from how did he
get a new shield
just by answering some of those
questions marvel could further cap's
narrative without altering his past
journey so let's break down what this
new cat movie could look like but before
we continue this video is sponsored by
soundcore in their liberty air 2 pro
earbuds
so soundcore just released the liberty
air 2
pros they are premium wireless earbuds
at a great
price the audio quality of these is
really impressive music just sounds
really great and even my bluetooth call
sounds super clear and they've got some
fancy cutting age tech in there but i
don't need to fully understand the tech
to just know that these sound incredible
the liberty air 2 pros have
three different noise cancellation modes
for when you're outdoors indoors or in a
really loud environment like a plane
taking off and as you can see they look
really great they come in black and
white and blue and pink and they fit in
your ear
really comfortably and for audiophiles
out there you can even customize your
eqs through the soundcore
app and get your levels just how you
like them soundcore has partnered with
music hairs a charity for struggling
musicians to provide support for
musicians facing financial or health
issues so your purchase
also helps folks that could really use
it right now get your soundcore liberty
air 2 pro
true wireless headphones by clicking on
the link in the description thanks again
to soundcore for sponsoring this video
okay so how will cap come back to the
mcu well i don't think we're looking at
more old man cap
why would you need chris evans for that
also that's a lot of aging vfx to budget
out for
and some deep uncanny valleys you could
easily trip into
so the returning cap is probably going
to be his younger self around evan's
current age
one option is for evans to cameo as a
scroll cap
in the secret invasion series on disney
plus while i won't rule that out
if i rule anything out never says never
i don't think a cameo in marvel's scroll
streaming series is what this reported
negotiations are over
one big unanswered question is what
happened when cap disappeared down that
quantum tunnel to return the infinity
stones in mjolnir there's definitely a
story there
problem is cap's return journey might be
better left
off screen cap forcing jane foster to
re-ingest the reality stone ether tap
running into red skull on board meredith
to try to return the soul stone
these might make for a fun episode of
like loki but that's not the worthy
narrative chris evans was talking about
really the answer is in old cap himself
what is that old man's story the story
that he's so coyly avoided telling sam
wilson well the end game screenwriters
have always maintained that old cap
lived out his life in the background of
the main mcu
timeline that there were just two caps
despite the problematic implications
that presents like it contradicting
their own branch timeline logic or
cap letting 911 happen the directors
meanwhile have stuck with the more
logical answer that cap must have lived
out his life in a branch history that we
just never saw a separate timeline
and found a way to travel back to the
present mcu timeline to give sam the
shield that alternate history is likely
where cap's next movie will be set a
revised
20th century timeline showing cap's life
with peggy
and his interactions with history
thereafter so within that alternate
history
cap's first priority after reuniting
with peggy would be to
go liberate his best friend bucky barnes
whom he would know to be in the clutches
of hydra in that
siberian winter soldier program it would
be cruel for steve rogers to just sit
idly by as his buddy was tortured into a
brainwashed killing machine to
eventually claim the lives of tony
stark's parents
so that logic tells us that this next
cat movie could be a
winter soldier film set in this
elseworld timeline within the marvel
multiverse
[ __ ] cat fighting hydra in the 50s or
the 60s
it wouldn't have to be cap tries to save
jfk leave that to loki
but just a grounded tale set in an
alternate history called war
it might require some multiverse
explanation to set it up but marvel
studios might be waiting to pull that
trigger until after those rules are more
clearly defined in wandavision or loki
or multiverse of madness
one clue right in front of us has been
old cap's new
shield and we know it's new because his
old one was shattered by thanos and left
in the rubble of that battle this one's
got some groovy new grooves
and it is about to be explored far more
deeply by sam and bucky in the falcon
winter soldier on disney plus
where did alt history cap get this i
have speculated it could be made out of
a different substance and vibranium like
roto adamantium as it is in the comics
and that true marvel history connects
with yup
wolverine the adamantium of wolverine
skeleton came from weapon x's
experiments
to try to replicate the proto-adamantium
of captain america's shield
we could get the answer of this history
with a cap supported
marvel studios wolverine because one of
marcus and mcfeely's ideas for that
first capped film
was to include in that pow camp that cab
liberated alongside the helen commandos
a soldier by the name of james logan
howlett
aka the regenerative forever soldier who
becomes wolverine
chris evans mcu return could be all
about the history of the x-men folks
all the pieces are in place and if old
cap can bridge to this reality from a
reality with mutants
that same bridge could be the way all of
those mutants come into the mcu
it's a true multiverse of madness folks
now again get your hands on that vision
unusual couple ar shirt just by going to
new rockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram
ea boss follow me rockstars and
subscribe for breakdowns of everything
you love
thanks for watching boom
[Music]
you